Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host, Ricardo Lobs. And today I'm
joined by Doctor Daniel Simons. He is a professor
in the Department of Psychology at the University of
Illinois where he also directs the visual cognition laboratory.
And today we're focusing on his latest book together
with Dr Christopher Chabris, who I've already have on
the show, by the way, nobody is fo why
we get taken in and what we can do
about it. So Dr Simons, welcome to the show.
It's a big pleasure to everyone. Thank you for
having me on. So tell us perhaps first a
little bit about the premise of the book. I
mean, I even have a quote here where you
say that it's basically about exploring the cognitive psychology
of the cheat, the patterns of thinking and reasoning
that make us all vulnerable to deception. Could you
explain that?
Yeah. And that's the broad theme of the book.
We took a look over many years at scams
and, and cons and just regular run of the
mill deception across a wide range of disciplines, everything
from investment fraud to cheating in chess to try
and see whether there were any commonalities across all
of them. And what we started to realize was
that there were some common tendencies that we all
have that make it possible for people to take
advantage of us. And there are tendencies that work
well most of the time. But that when somebody
is looking to take advantage of us, they co
opt them or hijack them for their own purposes.
So that was one theme that we found that
was really consistent across a wide range of kinds
of deception. The other was that any of us
can be fooled. We, we have this kind of
intuition that and belief that when you hear about
a fraud, you hear about somebody falling for a
scam. In retrospect, you can see all the red
flags they missed, you can see everything that they
didn't notice along the way. And that makes it
seem like they must be clueless or naive or
gullible. But the reality is that the scammers just
happen to target them well, for that particular scam
and any of us, no matter how educated, smart,
skeptical, critical thinking we are can be victimized if
the targeting is aimed at us.
Yeah. And we'll get into some of the aspects
of human cognition that you explore in the book
that make us susceptible, all of us susceptible to
deception. And I guess that that's uh very good
point because actually, I mean, almost every single time
that we hear about someone falling for what, for
us from the outside seems like a very basic
scam. We're always like, oh, it's because the person
was really gullible or stupid or dumb. Or it's
because she's low in intelligence. But that doesn't seem
to be really the case, at least most of
the time.
Exactly. And, and there's, there's so much entertainment industry
depiction of cons and scams. Right. And you can
go to the theater and see a heist movie,
you can listen to a podcast and hear all
about a con artist. But whenever you do that,
you know that there's deception taking place, you, you
are watching it knowing that it's about deception, which
means that you're looking for all of those hallmarks,
you're treating it more like a mystery where you're
trying to figure out where they went wrong. But
when somebody is immersed in the narrative themselves, when
they're, when they're the target of it, they don't
see it from that outside perspective, they only see
what they're being provided and that can lead to
anybody if it's targeted, appropriately being
fooled. But do you think that there is good
evidence that we have sort of a truth bias
that is that we most of the time tend
to believe or have this tendency to believe at
face value on what people are, what other people
are saying? And I mean, if so, is that
really a problem? Because isn't it that at least
most of the time, there's very good reasons to
think that what someone is saying is actually true.
Yeah.
Absolutely. And most of the time nobody's trying to
deceive us. So it makes sense for us to
accept what we're hearing is true most of the
time. That's what we call a truth bias. That
the idea of a truth bias is a little
more nuanced than, than just accepting everything is true.
It's the idea that whenever we hear something, whenever
somebody tells us something, our initial evaluation of what
they've said assumes it's true regardless of what it
is. And then it takes a little bit of
time or a little bit of effort to rip
it apart if we think it's wrong. So, and
you know, it's easier in some context than others.
If somebody says something that we firmly don't believe
or there's somebody that we don't ever trust, we
know not to trust them, we're going to discount
what they say pretty quickly. But um, we have
to take in what they're saying, process it make
sense of it. And part of that is kind
of like the need to accept that it's real
that it's true before we then debunk it. So
a truth bias is really a functional thing. We
have to have that otherwise we couldn't interact with
anybody around us, our society would not be able
to function. We have to trust that most of
the time what we're hearing is true. And that's
the base rate for that is good, right? That,
that's actually what we want to be doing. Um
The trick comes in how people who are trying
to deceive us, take advantage of that. They'll give
us some information that's not true, but then not
give us the opportunity to tear it apart or
to critique it or to realize that it's false?
And are there specific conditions where people remain uncertain
or skeptical of what someone claims? I mean, are
there specific situations, cases conditions where uh I mean,
even though for most situations, if someone just says
something that doesn't trigger in us, I mean, our
perhaps uh uh deception uh detecting or a device
or something like that. Uh I mean, that, that
we e even then think, OK, so in this
particular case, I will remain skeptical until I learn
a little bit more.
So I think we often do that we should
do it a lot more remaining uncertain is probably
the best thing we could do to avoid spreading
unintentionally spreading misinformation or repeating falsehoods. I if you
remain uncertain a little bit longer and look for
more information, that's a great strategy to make sure
you're not being fooled. Um And there, there certainly
are going to be context when we are going
to do that, right? We're going to be more
willing to be skeptical when it's something that we
had doubts about to begin with when it kind
of ran counter to our beliefs or our ideology
or our, you know, willing. So if somebody, for
example, provides scientific evidence, claims to provide scientific evidence
for ESP um I don't believe that's likely to
be true. I think there's plenty of good reasons
not to believe that that's true. Um As a
scientist, I should remain uncertain as long as I
can until the evidence becomes overwhelming. In that particular
case, I think it's pretty overwhelming, but let's say
that somebody provides some evidence for something that I
don't agree with, I don't think is likely to
be true, but it might be, well, that's a
context in which I should remain uncertain a little
bit longer. I should be willing to accept the
possibility that I was wrong um initially or that
the evidence that they're providing is wrong and that,
that's a great strategy to use. It's one that
we should use a lot more than we do.
Uh INCLUDING scientists, scientists don't remain uncertain as much
as they should. They're much more willing to take
on a strong belief and then discount anything that
runs counter to it. But we should remain uncertain
until the evidence is clear. The problem is we
rarely have the time or energy or willingness to
do all of the digging that we need to,
to show that it's actually clear.
Mhm And so let's get into the aspects of
human cognition you explore in the book that really
makes uh make us all susceptible to some, at
least some degree of deception. So you talk about
four different things, focus prediction, commitment and deficiency in
the book. So starting with focus, what is this
really about?
Yeah. So those four, those four elements are what
we call habits. So there are cognitive tendencies that
apply most of the time in our daily lives,
the things that we have to do that usually
are really, really effective for us. So focus is
the idea that we primarily direct our attention to
what we have right in front of us. The
information that we have most of the time, the
information we have is the information we need. So
it makes sense to focus on what we're doing,
what we're looking at what we're thinking about at
that moment. Um The challenge of focus is that
we often don't realize when we don't have information
that we might actually need and that's where we
run into problems. Um So the idea of focus
is that most of the time we use the
information at hand to do what we need to
do with it, to make sense of the world.
And that's usually a great thing and we usually
don't have to worry about all of the other
stuff that would just be distractions from the thing
we want to pay attention to. The problem comes
when the things that we're missing really should be
influencing our judgments, our decisions or our reactions to
the world and people who are looking to deceive
us will deliberately focus your attention on one thing.
So, if you've ever been to a magician's show,
a magic show, the magician is going to direct
your attention, they're going to get you to focus
on the effect what they're wanting you to see
and away from the method, the hidden information that
they're trying to, um, that they're trying to keep
away from you and they're going to do lots
of things to focus your attention. They're going to
have a lot of witty banter and joking that
gets you focused on what they're saying and not
what they're doing. But again, the idea is we
focus on a limited amount of information. We can't
focus on everything. And the end result of that
is sometimes the things that we're not focusing on
are things we need to pay attention to.
Uh YOU mentioned magicians there. But I guess that
there's another instance where people really try to make
us focus on just the positive aspects of, of
something and make us lose focus of the perhaps
more negative aspects of something. Like, for example, when
uh a company is trying to sell uh uh
uh its products, I, I mean, in advertisement and
all of that advertisement is basically all about that,
right? It's basically about focus and just focusing on
the positive aspects of products. So how do they
do that? Exactly.
Well, I mean, that, that's, they're just taking advantage
of the fact that we do that naturally. So,
advertising, I don't tend to think of advertising in
the same light as cons and deceptions. Um, THERE
they have a goal, they want you to think
about their product and not alternative products. They want
you to be directed attention to the positive features
of their product and not to the negative ones.
Right. So, um, so what do they do? They
just don't present the negative ones, they present only
the positive ones and we tend to kind of
think that those are representatives. So I think one
of the best examples of this is um demos.
So uh showing a video of a car driving
itself and we see that video and say, wow,
OK, I could, I would love to be able
to do that and just read a book while
the car is driving me to work. Um And
we think about all of the possible ways that
that same process could generalize. We assume that what
we're seeing is representative of what that car can
do. Um And we don't think about all of
the things that they haven't shown us things like
how many times did they try and do that
demo before it worked once? Um How many times
did the car drive off the side of the
road? How many times did it run a stop
light or a stop sign? Um We don't think
about those sorts of things. Does it only work
on straight roads? Does it only work in perfect
sunlight conditions or would it not work if it's
raining? What if a pedestrian ran out into the
road? We don't tend to think about those things
in real time while watching this demo. Instead, we
take it as representative, our focus on that demo
take treats it as typical of what happens in
the world and the end result is we just
don't think about the information we don't have. So
advertisers aren't having to do a whole lot to
get us to focus on their product. All they
have to do is present the information they want
us to have and they can kind of count
on us not thinking about the information we don't
have unless they say something really egregious, then we
might take a step back and say, wait a
second. Is that really true? And think about it,
in which case they've lost us, that's not what
they want us to do.
And I guess, I guess that apart from the
product, something that they do often is that they
present next to the product, high status or very
famous people, right? And that's another thing that perhaps
make us lose focus on some of the potential
negative aspects of the products. Right. Sure.
And that, that's actually tapping into one of the
hooks that I guess we'll talk about in a
little bit of familiarity. As well. It's, it's tapping
into the idea that for somebody who's a very
famous person we kind of feel like we know
them even though we really don't. And that familiarity
makes us trust things more. So. Yeah, they, they
use a lot of the advertising uses a lot
of these sorts of tactics. Um, THEY take advantage
of a lot of our strategies for how we
process information. Um, JUST like people looking to actually
deceive us
do. Mhm. And do you think that there are
perhaps some strategies, some things that we could do
to counter this tendency that we have to narrowly
focus on just one piece of information?
Well, I mean, it depends what you mean by,
by counter them. Can we make it so that
we can take in everything at once? No, I
mean, and, and people like to kind of think
so. So you might know my earlier studies with
people passing basketballs and a person in a girl
suit walking through a video. Um, AND people don't,
about half the time people who watch that don't
see the gorilla. Um, AND one of the most
common questions I get is, well, you know, what
can I do? So that I see the gorilla
and my reaction to that is first, there's nothing
you can do that would make it so that
you can always see unexpected things. And second, that
would be a terrible thing for you. You do
not want that because there are limits on how
much we can pay attention to and those are
structural limits on how our minds work. We all
have that sort of limitation we can't take in
everything all at once. Instead, we have this remarkable
ability to focus on what we care about and
to ignore distractions that's essential. Can you imagine trying
to drive down the road and not be able
to ignore everything that's going on on the buildings
next to you and on the sidewalks, that's irrelevant
to what you're doing. You'd be perpetually distracted. You
couldn't focus on what you needed to do and
an inability to focus is harmful. That's a problem
for a lot of people. Um WE all have
the ability to focus to some extent, right? We,
we can do that, but you can't get to
the point that you take in everything and notice
everything because then you couldn't focus anymore. And given
that we have limitations, we have a total amount
of resources that we're able to use. Anything you
use up on stuff that you don't care about
is stuff that you're not using for what you
do care about.
Mhm. And I guess that the aspect you mentioned
there about expectations leads us to the second habit.
You're exploring the book that has to do with
prediction. So what's that about?
Yeah. So prediction is uh the idea that we
tend to kind of look for the things that
we expect to be there and want to be
there. Um You can think of this as a
little bit like the idea of confirmation bias. We
tend to look for information that's consistent with our
beliefs as opposed to inconsistent with our beliefs. But
we, we frame this a little bit more broadly,
which is that um when we are given information
that fits what we predict, we tend not to
question it as much as we do when given
information we disagree with. So if you're online and
somebody posts something that is completely opposite to your
ide ideology or your politics, you're probably going to
be highly critical of it. And we're really good
at tearing apart things. We don't believe in. We
all have that sort of critical ability to rip
something into pieces. But if somebody happens to share
something that you happen to agree with, you're not
likely to dig into it as deeply as you
would otherwise. And if you don't dig into it,
you might not realize that it's based on weak
evidence. So you can pass off something that's not
true by making it consistent with what people want
to believe. And a huge amount of the misinformation
we see online is targeting people with information that
they believe it's not, it's not trying to fool
me into thinking something that I don't believe in
the first place. It's spreading it to people who
are likely to believe it who then spread it
along to other people and that makes it kind
of gain this sort of mass spread. Um So
the whole idea of that sort of viral transmission
is not, not persuading people who disagree with you
because they're going to tear it to pieces. It's
reaching the people who would agree and not think
critically enough. So, the idea of the, the habit
of prediction is that we, um we tend to
not think as critically about. We tend to accept
the truth of things that we expect and that
we predict more than things that we don't.
And perhaps linking here to one of the first
points we made in our conversation when we mentioned
that being deceived as very little or nothing to
do with people being more gullible or less intelligent.
I mean, I can't it be, can't it happen
that if someone is better at reasoning, they might
even be more blinded by their own expectations?
Yeah, there's some, there's some suggestions of that in
the literature that people reason really well, e even
for simple problems known as syllogisms, where you give
people a logical sequence, where you, you give them
two premises and then a conclusion. If that conclusion
fits your beliefs, you tend not to question whether
it's logically sound as much as you do if
it, if you disagree with it. So if you
have a conclusion that gun regulations save lives, which
is of course an issue in the United states,
um, not as much elsewhere in the world, fortunately,
uh for the rest of the world. But, um,
if you believe that gun regulation will save lives,
then a conclusion that fits that, even if it's
not logical, even if the premises don't lead to
that conclusion, you're going to tend to accept it
as true. Whereas if you think that gun regulations
are bad, you'll find the logical flaws and the
same thing. If you flip it, if you think
if you've reached the conclusion that gun regulations are
going to hurt safety, then if you believe that
you're not going to be as critical as of
premises that just that don't match it, right. They
don't actually lead to that conclusion. So, yeah, very
smart. People can tear apart conclusions that don't follow
if they disagree with them but are not as
critical when it comes to things that they agree
with
and can this sort of expectation based reasoning have
a negative impact specifically in science and the production
of scientific knowledge?
I think it's actually the biggest source of inadvertent
scientific errors, just mistakes. Um One way to think
about this is imagine you're doing a study and
you have a new experimental treatment and you want
to test it in a randomized clinical trial. So
you have a treatment and you have a placebo
and you expect the treatment to do better than
the placebo and that's what you find in your
results. So great. Publish it. What if you had
found that the placebo did better than the treatment?
What would you do as a scientist? You go
look at your data and see. Did I get
something wrong? Did I mislabel the columns? Did I
get them backwards? Um Were there some problematic data
points in there, were there some participants who weren't,
you know, assigned correctly? So you'd look for problems
and you look for mistakes And the key is
that you look for mistakes more when something is
unexpected and not what you predicted, and you're probably
less likely to do that when it's predicted. And
one of the most famous examples of this sort
of error um came from work by uh Reinhart
and Rogoff, who economists at Harvard, who were interested
in pushing the idea of austerity for fiscal austerity.
So they analyzed uh historical data from a bunch
of countries and their claim from their evidence was
that once the country's debt reached 90% of its
GDP that their economic growth tapered off, it crashed.
So that was an argument that we shouldn't be
spending our way out of economic problems because increasing
the debt is going to kill our economic growth.
Um The problem was that it was at the
conclusion, the data were actually based on an Excel
spreadsheet error. They didn't fill down an equation all
the way down to the bottom. They, they stopped
after 15 countries didn't go to all 20 countries
and the result doesn't hold if you actually include
the rest of the countries. So it literally was
just an error. Um And it was an innocent
mistake. I don't think there was any intentionality. There,
there was no fudging of data, there was no,
you know, there, there was no scamming going on
there, but they firmly believed this idea of austerity
and when the results happened to perfectly match it,
they ran with it. They didn't bother to check
it. I guarantee you that if that result had
come out the opposite, if they had filled down
and made a mistake in their Excel spreadsheet, that
had led to the claim that austerity was terrible
and that you could continue spending as much as
you want. And there's no problem, they would have
really triple checked their data and found the mistake.
So that creeps in all the time. I think
in scientific era that people are much more likely
to rigorously check things that don't match what they
predicted than there are things that perfectly match what
they predicted
and being realistic here. And since scientists are also
people and like other people, they have basically the
same psychology. Uh Do you think that uh since
we can't expect scientists to not have any expectations
at all that this would be a point in
favor of something like viewpoint diversity in science?
I I think the first thing we should assume
is that scientists always have opinions because we're human.
So we always have beliefs, we always have expectations.
We can't view things completely neutrally. Um I think
this is an argument for implementing policies that make
it harder for us to fool ourselves because the
real danger in science is fooling ourselves. Uh Most
scientists are not trying to fool other people, but
they can be fooled themselves and then they spread
information that's wrong. Um I think there are a
lot of things we can do to actually hedge
that. So one is to uh use different approaches
to publishing. So one is to write your analysis
scripts in advance of the study um before you
have any data and test them out with pilot
data that you know, has different characteristics. So that
when you apply to the real data, you know
that the analysis isn't going to have an Excel
spreadsheet error in other is to not use Excel
for your data analysis, but that's a different issue.
Um The other thing that I do in my
own lab now is that for every study we
do, um Typically I am a graduate student each
independently code the data analysis. So we, we write
the analysis separately ourselves and make sure that we
get the same results. And if we don't, normally
it's just something, you know, a tiny coding bug,
but you want to catch those before you publish
them and that catches these sorts of mistakes. Because
if we're both analyzing the data, it makes it
less likely that we're both going to make exactly
the same error in, in our analysis or exactly
the same error in our coding and you can
find the discrepancies and figure out what's wrong with
them. So I think those are good things to
do um in terms of ideological diversity. Yeah, I
mean, the real challenge is, of course, people aren't
going to believe the opposite side. There are plenty
of examples of this in science, you know, in
every field of science, um there are sub fields
in psychology, for example, where there are two sides
and they don't believe what the other side has
to say. And it doesn't really matter how strong
the evidence is, they won't listen to the other
side and that's not productive, right? We don't advance.
Um I don't think it's necessarily a terrible thing
for science as a whole because people outside of
that fight who don't have a stake in, it
can look at the evidence from the outside and
say, ok, well, here's what they're arguing about and
I find one side more plausible than the other.
So people not immersed in that fight, they're going
to be able to take a step back and
be more objective because they don't have, they don't
have a horse in the race, right? So for
them, it's not, it's not as ideologically, you know,
complicated um for the debate about, you know, I,
I think the debate about ideological diversity, I think
it's not just political diversity, it, it's having a
range of views so that you aren't all expecting
exactly the same outcome and that, that can be
true for a really narrow, boring question. You know,
is there memory for where you've searched items, letters
in a display before or after, after you've searched
that location? Is there any reference to that you've
been there before? That's, that's a debate within part
of the field I'm in. There's nothing, you know,
deep and meaningful to anybody outside of that debate,
but people within it are going to hold strong
views. That's ok. So, I, I think there's inherently
diversity in the sense of having different perspectives on
the same phenomenon, um, in science that otherwise there's
no interest in doing a study that everybody knows
will come out the same way. And I have
this discussion in my lab all the time that
if a student says I often have an undergrad
student who will propose a project. And it's like,
you know, wouldn't it be interesting if this were
true? It's like, oh, that's, that's great. But often
they'll propose a study that's, um, like, ok, and
I'll ask them, is there any reason anybody would
disagree with your prediction? And if there's not, then
maybe it's not as interesting to do it, it's
more interesting to do those studies where if it
comes out one way it supports one view if
it comes out a different way, it supports the
other view. And both of those are interesting. That's,
that's the optimal kind of study.
And the third habit you mentioned in the book
is commitment. So couldn't tell us first what commitments
are and perhaps the differences between assumptions and commitments
because that's also something you explore in the book.
Yeah. So a commitment is an assumption that's held
so firmly that we no longer are willing to
question it and we don't think about it at
all anymore. It just becomes ingrained in how we
act. So we all make assumptions all the time.
We have to, you have to, we don't always
have all the information. We have to assume a
lot of things about the world and about how
other people are acting with us. And so assumptions
are, are normal. What we expect commitments are when
they can sometimes become uh maladaptive. So, so often
we want to have strong commitments to some things,
right? We, we, we that's not necessarily a bad
thing. Most of the time the problem comes when
you are so firmly committed to something and it
happens to be wrong that you don't question it.
So I think my favorite example of this from,
from the book uh was um a discussion of
a person who was a victim of Bernie Madoff's
Ponzi scheme. So the investment Ponzi scheme fraud biggest
Ponzi scheme in the modern era. Um And there
were a number of people who were questioning what
was going on with Madoff's scheme. They were suspicious
that there was something fraudulent going on. And one
of them told one of his customers that had
a customer whose parents were heavily invested in NADO.
And he's told this customer it's like, you know,
you should tell your father this isn't good. He
should be getting out of this. Um, HE shouldn't
be trusting this and the father's response was, well,
he just doesn't know Bernie. I know Bernie and
Bernie would never screw us. That's a commitment. It's
so firmly beheld that there's no way that Bernie
Madoff could possibly be somebody who would treat us
badly. And when you're committed to that belief, anything
goes, you, you're not willing to take a step
back and say, could this be a fraud because
he'd never screw us? It's a, it's a firm
commitment and we see commitments going leading people astray
in a lot of sort of conspiracy thinking. And
in politics where people are so firmly holding the
belief that this person, this politician, this person I
like is infallible. They can do no wrong. They
only tell the truth that you have to go
to incredible lengths to kind of make all of
their inconsistent statements hold together because you've got that
commitment that you can't back away from and it
can lead you down this conspiratorial rabbit hole where
you try and find all of these things to
make everything work. It's like trying to find ways
to make it so that all of the planets
in the sun are orbiting the earth. Right? If
you start with that assumption, you can find all
sorts of weird convoluted ways to make it seem
like it kind of works given the evidence at
hand, even though it's wrong and for anybody on
the outside who doesn't have that commitment, it seems
crazy, But from the inside, it's logically coherent and
that, that's where you run into these problems where
people can't talk to each other because one has
a commitment that's so firm that they've gone down
an entire path of logic, very reasonable, entire path
of logic starting from that commitment that they never
questioned.
But psychologically speaking, when it comes to this move
from a simple assumption to a commitment, what is
it based on exactly? Is it trust, confidence or
some other thing?
You know, that's a great question and I don't
have a great answer for it. It's, uh the,
the, I think the key challenge for making sure
that you're not being deceived is thinking about what
are the assumptions that you won't question. And sometimes
those, you know, those are reasonable assumptions. Um, YOU
know, I have an assumption that people can't predict
random events better than chance. And I think there's
a lot of evidence to back that assumption, but
it's an assumption. Um, IF I became firmly committed
to it, even if somebody were to come along
and prevent present unquestionable evidence at some level, I
wouldn't accept it. And that's for a scientist that
becomes a problem when you're so committed that you
won't look at evidence that challenges your perspective. That's
when it's moved into commitments rather than assumptions. And,
um, but what, what leads people to go that
route? That's, it's a great question. I wish I
had a strong answer for it.
That's fair enough. So let's get into the final
habit before we talk about the four hooks you
want to explore in the book. So, efficiency, what,
what does that mean in this context? Exactly. Well,
efficiency is just a tendency. We have to try
and get things done in the fastest way and
simplest way we can with the least effort, which
the vast majority of the time is exactly what
we want to do. You don't want to take
the long way to work, you want to get
there quickly. So, um efficiency is, is usually a
great thing and it just means that we sometimes
don't ask questions when we should. Um So when
people are looking to deceive us, they take advantage
of the fact that we aren't likely to ask
more questions. We're not likely to dig deeper and
we take glib empty answers as good enough so
that we can move on. And one way to
think about this is it can be really uncomfortable
and awkward to ask for more information. So imagine
you're at a psychic performance and you stand up
and say, well, you know, do you, do you
actually know that this person had bone cancer? Um
You know, or, well, you started with Rob and
then you said Bobby, uh why did you start
with Bobby? Those sorts of questions are awkward to
ask and imagine you're getting a, a business pitch.
Um Somebody's pitching your, you and they want to
um they want to be a consultant for you
and they cite all of their, you know, success
stories like, well, that's great. Um It's really uncomfortable
to ask, what are all your failure stories? How
many other companies have you, have you uh consulted
for that? Didn't get these results? Um You know,
asking those sorts of questions is exactly what we
need to get more information. It's, it's, you know,
it's recognizing when somebody is getting us to focus
on the information they're presenting. And in that for
the sake of efficiency, we often don't question even
when we probably should. We take empty answers as,
as good enough like, oh, well, it's been validated.
What does that mean? We're using best practices whenever
somebody says that it often means that they can't
define what a best practice is. Um My favorite
of these is somebody saying, well, we're being transparent
whenever somebody says that they're not being transparent because
being transparent means showing not say not telling, right?
Showing what you've done. So if you're being transparent,
like, well, how are you being transparent? What, what
have you shown us? Um I've run into that
all the time. Like university administrators bragging about how
transparent they're being when they haven't actually given any
information.
Yeah. Uh BUT don't you think, and if you
disagree, please tell me, but don't you think that
there are perhaps situations cases where when it comes
to asking more questions, uh perhaps uh we are
simply not sure about what are, what are the
correct questions to ask because we are not familiar
with that particular kind of subject or where someone
might be trying to sell us, for example. And
in that case, I mean, it's also a lack
of information. Uh And the fact that because we
lack that information, we don't really know what questions
we should ask.
I think that's exactly right. That much of the
time, we don't know what, what information we still
need, we don't know what to ask. And of
course, people are going to take advantage of that
because people are going to be not confident about
asking a question if they don't have some idea
of what they want to get out of it.
Um So that's how, that's how people will bluster
past you and take advantage of your efficiency. It's
efficient not to ask questions. Um It's also efficient
to avoid kind of making yourself uncomfortable, right? Because
that's just gonna take more effort and energy. Um
But I think there are a lot of things
you can do just to, to start asking questions
that sometimes will reveal more even if you don't
quite know what you want. So, one good thing
is what else can you tell me or say
more? And it's not a question but it gets,
gets whoever you're talking to, to, to talk more
and you know, that, that's like that standard sort
of trope of detective movies where, you know, you've
got the, got the person who you think is
the criminal there and you just want them to
talk more so they give them, give away information,
same principle in cases that aren't that adversarial just
say, OK, can you, can you tell me a
little more or say more about that? Um And
if you do that people will talk more and
if they talk more, that might raise more specific
questions you could ask. So that's, that's a good
tactic to just start out. Um Another, another question
you can ask, that's a little more directed that
uh that we'll get more information is what could
you tell me that might make me disagree with
you, which is, um, a way of kind of,
you know, eliciting this information that, you know, we
really need. Um, THAT, that's the sort of question
that I recommend that journalists ask when they talk
to scientists, like who might disagree with this position.
And why would they disagree with you? And any
scientists should be able to answer that and say,
ok, well, here's why somebody might disagree with my
position. Here's why I think they're wrong, but here's
why they might disagree. And that gives you an
end to what are the commitments that they have?
What are their assumptions, um, who might have different
sets of assumptions and who could you ask about
them? So, the whole idea is to get people
to give you information that they wouldn't spontaneously give
you if they were trying to take advantage of
your willingness not to ask questions and you're willing
just to kind of get through things efficiently.
Uh Also because in this particular case, I would
imagine that if you're not familiar with the whatever
the other person is talking about or trying to
sell you, for example, that's also a way of
getting more information. And I mean, if at the
end of the conversation, you still do not fully
understand what they're trying to sell you, then perhaps
it's just better to not
buy. Yeah. And I think that's often the often
the case, right? That more often than not the
reason for asking questions is to get more information.
Well, one way to get more information is to
ask really focused questions. If you happen to know
enough to ask those, the other is just to
get the person to talk more because when somebody
is trying to advertise to you. They want to
show you just the information they have in front
of them that they want to provide you. If
they have to talk more, if they just start
repeating themselves, then you know that they actually don't
have anything to say. But if they can provide
more information that you might have a better understanding.
So, yeah, absolutely. That's, that's the whole idea is
take a moment, even if it's just asking one
or two more questions, when you're making an important
decision can get you a lot more information and
often one question will lead to others.
Mhm And related still to efficiency. There's this concept
of opportunity costs. I mean, what are opportunity costs
and why is it that sellers usually do not
want you to consider them?
Yeah. So I mean, opportunity costs. The simple way
to think about an opportunity cost is what else
could you do with your time or money? Um
And would you prefer that? So um somebody is
trying to sell you something means that they want
to take your money for their product, which means
you don't have that money available for anything else
for any to invest or to buy something different.
Um So they want to focus you on the
benefits of their product and they don't want you
to think about what else you could use that
money for because then you might not buy the
product. So um a lot of the goal of
advertising, of course, is to get you to buy
things without thinking about opportunities that you might have
if you use the money for something else. Um,
I, I think, uh, yeah, I mean, I think
that's the basic idea of, of opportunity costs. Um,
ONE thing to think about for opportunity costs is
that, you know, thinking about all of those opportunity
costs is inefficient. So if you have to think
about all of the other things that you might
do instead that slows you down, it means that
you're not making quick decisions, you're having to, you,
you're trying to decide which of several strategies you
want to use for your business. That means, you
know, thinking about what would happen if you didn't
do any of those. Um IT takes extra time,
it takes extra effort. So anticipating opportunity costs and
thinking about them is inefficient in the sense that
we don't just plow ahead and get done and
we have a strong drive to do that. So
countering that when it matters is the key. You
don't, you don't want to think about opportunity costs.
Every time you go to the grocery store and
decide to buy a box of cereal, you don't
want to stop and think what else could I
use this money for other than cereal? You know,
if I, if I need breakfast food, I could
think about other breakfast food. But what if I
invested that money now? And you know how much
value would it have to me later if I
skipped breakfast, you don't want to go through that
sort of thought process every time you do anything
you want to think about when it matters and
when it doesn't.
And so we've gone through the four main psychological
habits, I guess that make us vulnerable to deception
getting now into the hooks that people use to
deceive us. So in the book, you go through
consistency, precision, potency and familiarity starting with consistency, what
do you that is really about in this context?
But let me step back and say what hooks
hooks are. So um we think of hooks as
information in a form that we find really attractive.
So people who are looking to deceive us are
going to present information in a way that appeals
to us that we find more likely to be
true um that we don't think as much about.
So again, it's one of those tactics people use
to get us to stick with our initial assessment
that something is true and not to question it
as much. And all of these hooks lead us
to sort of jump right in without thinking. So
the metaphor I like to use for this is
um a bull fight, a matador. And so the
matador stand there perfectly still with their red cape
and they're going to wave that cape around and
the bull finds that irresistible and charges um charges
right in without realizing that, you know, there's a
blade behind it. Um So that, that sort of
running in without thinking about it, um is what
happens when we get information that we find particularly
appealing and it's not always just blindly running in,
it's just accepting something is true when we maybe
shouldn't. So, um the first of those that you
mentioned is consistency, which is, and, and again, just
like for the habits, the vast majority of time,
these kinds of information are really good, they're really
useful. Consistency is a perfect example of that. Usually,
if something is consistently the case, that means it's
reliable, that means it's predictable, that means we can
count on it. Um And those are typically great
things for most of what we do in the
world, having something to be consistent is terrific. That's,
that's what we want it to be. Um The
problem comes in that we don't always recognize first
when we shouldn't expect consistency. Um And don't look
for when it should be varying. But second, when
somebody is looking to deceive us, they use these
hooks, they'll present these hooks without having the underlying
truth behind it. So somebody will present information that
seems really consistent because it's fabricated, not because it's
actually genuine and, and reliable and robust. So uh
in fabricated data, um this is something that happens
in science, you know, unfortunately, more often than we
like, um people will, people who have committed scientific
fraud often will present results that are consistently great.
They get the same result every single time and
just as strong an effect, every single time when
in reality, that's not how randomness works. And it's
not how human behavior typically works. You don't always
get the same thing every single time, especially in
sort of a field where there's a lot of
randomness inherent in it. Um EVEN in physics where
you're measuring something really, really precisely. Um And you
want to get the same results every time there's
still randomness in the measurement and it's not going
to be exactly the same to an infinite level
of precision every single time you expect that noise.
So if somebody gave you exactly the same thing
to 20 decimal places, every single time, you'd worry
about it. You should be worried about it because
that doesn't account for how random things are. Um
So somebody who's committing fraud will present that consistency
because we like consistency. It appeals. If somebody can
get the same results every time, it's like, wow,
that must be true. And the reality is that
yes, if they genuinely got the same result every
time, that'd be great. And we use that as
a great rule of thumb most of the time.
But when somebody is committing fraud, they just don't
have to do the data, don't have to do
the actual studies. They can just make up consistent
data. And that appeals to us and we don't
think critically enough about it.
So it's basically that idea if it's too perfect
or too good to be true. So, I mean,
if it, if it sounds like that then prep
probably it's not true.
Well, and that, that's the challenge, right? Because what
sounds too good to be true to one person
sounds just good enough to another. Um And so
it becomes really difficult to use that rule of
thumb consistently because you know, something AAA con artist
or a scammer who is targeting you is going
to make it sound just good enough. Whereas the
person next door to you who hears that same
pitch might say that's ridiculous. That's way too good
to be true, right? So it, it has to
be targeted appropriately. And I think targeting is what
counts for whether you think it's too good or
just good enough, but they're going to present information
that is good enough that you will accept it
as true and they use all of these hooks.
But consistency is I think in science, one of
the most common ones um to give you data
that just seems great. So I think one of
the famous examples of this is Jan Hendrik Schon
who's a, was a German uh uh in America
in Bell Labs, but he, he um studied uh
superconductivity back in the early two thousands and was
a physics superstar young guy at what was then
uh Bell labs and he published, I think 16
papers in the journals, Nature and Science, the top
two science wide journals, 16 papers in two years
himself. And that's, that's like the output of an
entire top notch physics department in in two years,
it might be higher than that. So superstar um
publishing evidence of superconductivity with different materials. And um
it turns out that uh if you line up
all the papers next to each other, he was
reusing the same data uh and just changing the
axes and changing the materials and changing the voltages
in, in the figures. But the figures were the
same um they were likely just manufactured. It's not
clear that there was ever any result. But that
cost, you know, hundreds of labs, more than 100
labs had spent years trying to replicate his works
and millions and millions of dollars trying to replicate
his work. Um So it had consequence, but the,
the hallmark of the the misconduct there was that
the images were the same, the data were too
consistent to be possible. Um And the thing I
find most interesting about this sort of scientific misconduct
and scientific fraud is it's out there in the
open. It's literally in the publications, you can see
that it's too consistent to be true, but it
gets past peer reviewers and editors and other scientists
for a variety of reasons. It seems really good,
it seems consistent, you know, and people don't ask
one more question, they process it efficiently, they read
it quickly and say, oh, yeah, he found this
again and that sounds like a positive when in
reality it should be a red flag.
Mhm. Yeah. And that's the thing, right. Even earlier
when we talked about the scientists, that's another sort
of evidence that we can look into, uh, and
make the case that scientists really are like, uh
other people because in, uh, if it goes past
uh peer review and all of that, I mean,
it's not at least not usually the case that
people who are reviewing the studies are really incompetent.
It's just that they are most of the time
relying on these psychological habits.
Yeah, I mean, and, and we can't dig into
the details of every aspect of every paper and
compare them to every other paper that somebody has
written in real time. While we're also doing our
own work, people have to be efficient. Um But
I think this is a great example because it
does illustrate that we all can be fooled by,
by people trying to deceive us, especially if those
people who are trying to deceive us are at
all sophisticated about it. But the people who are
being fooled in the sciences are generally pretty smart,
um definitely highly trained, they're trained to be critical
thinkers, they're trained to evaluate evidence and they still
can be fooled. We all can be if it's
targeting it, right. And if you look at a
lot of the scientific fraud that's out there more
often than not. It's not earth shattering or groundbreaking
work more often than not. It is kind of
what we would predict in, in a field or
at least kind of what a lot of people
in that field would predict and expect. Um It's
often a little bit more impressive in some way.
So it's methodologically heroic. It took a huge amount
of effort to do or it used a group
of uh participants or subjects or, you know, a
population or animals that are hard to access. Um
So that makes it more impressive, right? It, it
usually is slightly cleaner, uh slightly better than what
other people have found. Um So the result is
that it kind of fits right in with other
sorts of studies that have been published, but improves
on them a little bit. So it makes that
person seem like they're just that much better than
the other people around them but not doing something
so extraordinary that people immediately doubt it. So a
contrast example for this is um in, you know,
some years ago, a famous paper published in the
top journal in social psychology claimed to find evidence
that people could predict random events better than chance,
right? So essentially a form of psychic ability and
the immediate reaction to that was no, that's not
right. It can't be right. Um So the question
then is what's wrong with it. Um, BUT that
was because it didn't fit into what people already
believed and it wasn't fraudulent. I think he just,
it was somebody fooling themselves, um, you know, with
their analysis and there were lots of issues with
how they did their analysis. But, um, it wasn't
fraud and that would have been a dumb study
to make up right, as a fraud because people
would immediately discount it and start digging into it
and looking into the problems with it. So the
things that kind of survive as frauds for a
while before they get caught are typically not outlandish
claims. They are typically landish just, you know, slightly
slightly, you know, slightly impressive. They, they land in
the right spot.
They are physically credible enough,
credible enough, right? They, they, they're still impressive, but
they're credible enough and credible enough within the realm
of other things that have been published in that
area. And that, that's kind of the typical finding.
So I think a great example of science working
correctly and not necessarily involving fraud is, you know,
claims of room temperature fusion which have come and
gone repeatedly over the years in physics. Um, THERE
have been cases of fraud in, in that world,
but more often than not, it's just somebody who's,
there was something odd about the materials they're working
with and they didn't figure out what it was
and it sounded good. So they went with the
claim that it was, you know, called fusion and
then physicists immediately dug into it because that's a
big claim. Right? And big claims require very strong
evidence and people will dig into them more. Um,
THAT'S, you know, that's part of why those sorts
of claims garner so much attention is that they
are out there, they are a little too far
and that's if, and they're one of those, if
true, that would be amazing sorts of findings. And
anytime you hear, like, if that's true, that would
be amazing. You should be skeptical about it because,
you know, amazing breakthroughs are pretty rare.
Right? So, getting into the second hook, familiarity, I
think that we've already mentioned this briefly earlier in
our conversation. But what does familiarity indicate to us?
Exactly. So, usually familiarity is a great cue to
something being trustworthy. So, imagine, you know, your friends,
your family, people, you know, personally, um, if you've
been around them for a long time, you know,
whether or not you can trust them and you
know, how much to trust what they say and
how much to discount it. Right. We all have
that relative. We don't trust what they say. But
for the most part, if you're around people a
lot that familiarity makes it reasonable to continue to
trust, to accept the truth of what they're saying
without questioning it as much, it makes the truth
bias reasonable. Um, AND that's, that's a great cue
for, for us most of the time. Um, IT
becomes a problem in terms of deception because we
mistake superficial familiarity with genuine familiarity. So we see
a celebrity a lot, we hear a lot of
interviews with them. We kind of feel like we
know them and because we kind of feel like
we know them, we tend not to be as
critical when they say something, you know, as we
should. Um, ROMANCE scams, um which are a major
source of scams, financial scams and other sorts of
scams right now, often targeting older folks who are,
are lonely, um, divorcees or widowers or widows. Um
AND they, the way they work, it's almost entirely
online and they establish over time familiarity. They feel
you feel like you're getting to know this person
who you're interacting with a lot online, but you've
never actually met them in person and they probably
look nothing like what they tell you they do.
Um And that's those scams are really effective because
we confuse the sort of familiarity we sort of
evolved with interacting with people directly having close associates
that we know really well. Um And can distinguish
from people we don't know very well. We confuse
that with, you know, friends on Facebook who you
might never have met in person or you encounter
only on social media and people can present a
persona um very easily. So somebody looking to deceive
you is going to take advantage of that present
themselves like they like a friend would and take
advantage of that experience of familiarity.
And what about uh precision? So what does it
mean to be precise here? And uh but basically,
how do, how can we distinguish reliable information from
detailed concrete information? That is just BS,
that's the real challenge, right? And that's why these
hooks can fool us so easily. Um So usually
if somebody can give you a precise answer and
it's grounded, it's based on real evidence. That's great.
That's really impressive. So that physicist who can measure
some constant to six decimal places, that's great. They
can do it reliably, they can give you the
exact number more or less. Um And that precision
means that they have great understanding. Um A weather
forecaster who can say that it's going rain will
cover 25% of this region uh between two and
four tomorrow. That's a great prediction that's precise. Um
And to the extent that they are calibrated and
do it well, that means they have a good
understanding of the weather pattern for that day. Um
Much better. It's much more informative than saying it
might or might not rain sometime in the next
three days. But that doesn't, that doesn't have any
value to us. So we value precision because precision
usually is a sign of great understanding. The problem
of course, is anybody looking to deceive us can
just fake precision. They'll give us numbers and those
numbers don't necessarily have any meaning to them. That's
where we run into problems that um it's very
easy to give a precise number and make it
seem like it's something genuine when there's no actual
evidence backing it.
Mhm. Uh And when, when, when it comes to
potency, there is the last hook. What is it
really about?
So, potency is, are you almost like, you know,
the desire for big fixes, quick fixes that one,
you know, this one simple trick will fix your
problem. And there's a reason why that Clickbait works
well on, on social media. We all want the
sort of quick fix the easy solution, the, you
know, become a master at something in just a
few hours. Um That sort of ability to radically
change things with the minimal effort. So big effects
from small, small effort, a small intervention, there are
rare cases where that holds true where a tiny
little thing can have a gigantic effect. The discovery
of antibiotics, vaccines, huge consequences from a tiny little
thing, right? That's um those are, you know, those
are rare and few and far between. But we
have this tendency to kind of assume that things
should be easier than they are that we can
stave off the effects of cognitive aging by playing
a brain game for 10 hours like nope, not
gonna work. Um But that, that potency, that desire
for potent effects genuinely is a good thing when
it's true. It's just that we see it far
more often than we think we do. And people
who are looking to deceive us always take advantage
of that one, right, that they can, who are
trying to sell us some sort of fake product
will always claim giant benefits from something that really
doesn't have giant benefits. Um As a general rule,
big consequences require big interventions. You, you don't get,
you don't get a big outcome from a small
thing.
Mhm A and again and again, I imagine that
here, as we said, it has nothing to do
or very little to do with cognitive ability, but
with lack of information. Because if, for example, you
are a scientist of a particular area and you
uh are advertised something uh that promises to get
huge benefits from very small investment or from a
very small thing. And you are sort of familiar
with what they're talking about. They would, you would
say immediately, oh this is just BS come on.
It's much more complicated than that. But people who
just lack that sort of knowledge are much more
vulnerable to that kind of advertisement, for example.
And even even scientists fall for this sort of
stuff all the time, right? There is, there is
an entire field of um what sometimes is called
social priming where you, you kind of flash some
words briefly or have people these scramble sentences. And
the claim was doing that sort of trivial task
would have these big effects on behavior, right? That
would actually change what you do. And it was
sort of a cottage industry and social psychology to
generate these effects that were more and more kind
of outlandish, like, you know, scrambling and unscrambling sentences
related to being old makes you walk more slowly.
It just doesn't none of those hold up. Um
But there are tons and tons of papers in
the literature on this Um big interventions designed to
remedy really complex social problems. Um Things like uh
there, there are a whole series of studies recently
that are called sometimes called wise interventions and they're
called wise interventions. The idea is that they don't
require much effort and they are highly efficient and
lead to these big outcomes. So their claims that
like doing a one hour affirmation in a school
at the beginning of school, uh reduces disparities in
suspensions for black and white kids um or increases
academic achievement two years later, like, you know, these
are really complex multiply determined problems in society, right?
The suspension gap has there's so many factors that
contribute to that suspension gap and it's not just
something that's going to go away with a one
hour, you know, thinking about yourself intervention. Um BUT
these things are pervasive in the schools, um growth
mindset interventions, you probably have heard of growth mindset.
Um Yeah. So there are claims that, you know,
one hour affirmation, you know, one hour growth mindset,
intervention is going to change your academic performance sometime
later. Like no, you know, that you, you'd be
hard pressed to find a school district in the
United States, at least that doesn't apply growth mindset
in some way. And it's a big industry now.
Um If you look, there's a recent meta analysis
of all of these interventions and most of them
had severe method problems, most of them didn't actually
even measure whether the intervention changed people's mindsets. Um
And if you look at the handful of them
that did it, well, there's basically no effect of
these interventions on academic performance or outcomes. So it's
one of these things where it's, you know, a
tiny little intervention to address something that's a big
societal complex problem. And people find those really appealing
and aren't sufficiently critical of them when they, when
they are made because as scientists, we should be
always skeptical of big effects from small interventions, but
they appeal a lot when they're true. And if
it were true, it would be amazing, right? If,
if it were true that you could just spend
an hour and fix a major problem, that would
be great. Just we tend to find it more
appealing than we should.
Yeah. And I mean, I guess that generally speaking,
if we're talking about the multifactorial issue, if someone
claims that just targeting one single factor will solve
it, uh it's probably not going to happen.
Yeah. And there's there's a sort of, you know,
desire to find the single, the single solution, the
single cause, um fixing one thing to fix all
the things. And, you know, often that's not a
terrible approach to, to look for, to try and
find that single cause. This is a common practice
in medicine, right? If you have somebody who's got
a bunch of symptoms, you want to look to
see is there one thing that's causing all the
symptoms? Um, AND often there is, and that's, that's
the simplest possible explanation for what's going on. Uh,
IN these cases, it's more commonly, there's one issue
that we want to address. There's basically one symptom,
say racial disparities in suspensions or, um, and we
have that one issue but it's caused by many,
many things and those are cases where fixing one
of those many, many things isn't going to likely
have a complete effect on the outcome. It's, it
works great when you've got one cause for many
symptoms. It doesn't work so great when there's many
causes for one symptom.
Right. So, I have two or three more questions
before we wrap up the interview about the hooks.
Is it that the best deceivers out there resort
always to all four Hooks or can they just
resort to one or two of them or does
it work? Exactly.
I, I think it, it varies a lot. Um,
BASED on what's necessary to pull somebody in and
what the, what the scope of a deception is
for something that's just sort of AAA, very limited,
you know, limited sort of fooling somebody just, you
know, quick encounter where they're just trying to pass
off some product they might not use more than
one or two of these. Um, SOMETHING that's a
long running scam, um, likely has to adopt a
lot more of them. So take, uh Bernie Madoff's
Ponzi scheme, I think that's a good example of
one, you know, ran for 15 plus years um
where he didn't process a single transaction, they were
all faked for for that longer duration. And so
he, you know, he, he used focus to some
extent because he's going to give you the information,
you want your returns but not tell you all
of the details about how he managed to do
that. You know the missing information. He's counting on
you not asking how is it that you managed
to get identical returns month to month, year to
year because nobody else can. Um So most people
don't ask that most people don't ask for more
information than he provides. And he, he um he
set people up to expect the same returns every
year. They would get their 8 to 14% every
year, not having any down years. And as long
as they kept getting what they expected, people didn't
complain, they didn't question it. If they had a
big down year, he would have, they would have
questioned it, but he gave them what they expected.
He counted on commitments as we already discussed that
people trusted him and they didn't think he would
be ever the sort of person who would screw
them over. He was also familiar to many of
the people who invested with him. He uh specifically
targeted members of his social community in New York,
e especially um he selected the people who could
invest with him. Um He didn't just let anybody
invest with him, he would turn people away. Um
So he selected the people who he was, he
was in, who are investing with him. Um He
used precision. So he would give people this huge
print out of every of records of trades that
were all fabricated um in their, you know, in
their reports, it wasn't online like it would be
for most major investors. It was just all of
these trade transaction forms. So lots of detail there
that just didn't have anything backing it. It was,
it was a perfect example of, you know, giving
precise information without any substance to it. Um Potency,
maybe he didn't use a whole lot because we
think of potency as the classic Ponzi scheme where
invest now and you're guaranteed 50% returns in six
months. He never did that. In fact, he kind
of performed about the same as the S and
P 500 the major stock index over the course
of his Ponzi scheme. His investment wasn't that outstanding?
It was just stable. It was, you never had
a down year with Bernie. Um So he used
consistency a lot more than he used potency. But
yeah, I mean, he, he used a lot of
these techniques and how he went about it,
which in a way perhaps made it even more
grabbable.
Yeah. Well, in order to keep it, keep it
going that long, he would have to tap into
a lot of the sort of ways of thinking
that keep people from questioning the truth of what
he's saying. So, yeah, that's, that's, that's right. The
longer something goes, the more complex it is, the
more they're going to have to rely on deceiving
you in different ways.
Uh And another question I have here is so
we've already mentioned several times how this has very
little or nothing to do with people's cognitive ability
or any other kind of psychological threats. But isn't
it the case that many times scammers or receivers
target specific vulnerable people? Of course, to do that,
they have to have specific kinds of information about
specific people. I mean, some, sometimes they target just
the elderly in general, sometimes they might target very
specific niches of people. Like for example, if it's
a romantic scam, they might target people that they
know are single and do not like to be
single or something like that. But I, I mean,
it's also the case that uh the, some of
the most successful scammers are also the ones that
know who to target.
So there are two different approaches, right? And there
undoubtedly are some people who are more gullible than
others. There are going to be individual differences there.
I don't think that's the defining factor in whether
or not somebody can be scammed. So I think
the danger is in assuming that because you're a
smart critical thinker that you can't be, can't be
deceived. Um That's undoubtedly wrong. Uh The, the idea
that some people are more likely to be seed
than others is certainly true and some people are
more easy to target than others. But there are
two different approaches that scammers can take. One is
uh to specifically learn a lot about a person
and meet them where they are. So, yeah, if
you're a romance scammer, you're not going to target
somebody who's happily married. That's just not going to
be an effective target. If you are using the
calling card scam, which is a standard tactic or
the call center scam where people will call up
people targeting them for a particular uh fear. So
often in the scams are often based out of
other countries. And then we'll call in to say
the United States and we will target people who
are here on a limited visa status or, or
here illegally and we threaten them with deportation or
with arrest unless they pay up right away. That
scam is not going to work on me. It's
no work on somebody who is an immigrant. Um
And there are variants of it that will work.
There are variants of that, that work on professors,
right? There's a, there's a variant of this right
now, which is really clever. So if you are
a professor who gives invited talks at conferences, um
on occasion, uh quite often the conference organizers will
arrange your hotel and some of your travel for
you. So um there's a con right now that's
working pretty effectively um where the con artist will
look at the conferences, figure out who's invited to
speak. And we call those people and pretend to
be the conference organizers to arrange their travel and
they'll arrange their hotel and flight information, which means
they get all of their personal information and their
credit card and they have nothing to do with
the conference. They just looked up the information and
targeted. So again, professors can fall for this and
have. Um So that's one approach is the specific
targeting. The other approach is to allow the victims
to select themselves. Um So I don't know if
you have this particular scam in, in Portugal, but
uh where you get an automated call asking you
about extending your cars warranty. Do you guys have
that one? I
got that not about a car warranty about other
things, but yeah, I, I got, I got that
kind
of thing. So these are these robocalls. It's like
most people like, yeah, those are scam. Um But
the people who call it back have just identified
themselves as somebody who is a target. It's somebody
who is concerned about their car's warranty. So they,
they self identified. So the scammers there don't have
to waste any time selecting people. All they have
to do is just blast it out to as
many people as possible. And then some people will
respond same thing with the original Nigerian prints email
scam, which has been going on for decades now.
It, it was, it existed before email. Um AS,
as letters. Um But the idea of that scam
is they can send out now millions of those
emails, most of which look ridiculous, right? Most people
are not going to fall for that. Um There's
bad grammar. It's weird, you know, I still get
these in my inbox, um mostly caught by the
spam filters now. But um, but if you think
about it, they're not trying to reach you or
me. They're trying to reach those very small number
of people who have not heard of this scam
and who will respond to that email. So they
want to make it as obvious as possible so
that they don't have to waste any time with
people who aren't going to eventually pay up. They
want only the most gullible, they want the person
who calls back about their car's warranty. So anybody
who responds to that email is a likely target
and it's cost efficient for them because they don't
have to waste time with all of the people
who are more skeptical of that particular email. So,
yeah, they scams are targeted in, in different sorts
of ways either by selecting and really getting to
know the people you're, they're trying to victimize or
by allowing people to select themselves.
So, my last question, then I guess that we
can say here that there's no foolproof way of
being able to always identify the scammers and the
deceivers. But I guess that the point of your
book here is for people to be more aware
of the fact that we have this sort of
psychological habits, this truth bias and to perhaps in
specific situations, be more aware and wary of certain
things that people say and, and perhaps ask more
questions in specific situations as well and stuff like
that. Uh Because most of the time our proof
bias still works. Most
of the time, all of these things still work.
Um Most of the time, none of us are
very few of us are going to be victims
of a grand con, right? Most of us are
not going to succumb to that. We'll, we'll all
be fooled by misinformation at times. We'll all be
fooled by deception and every now and then we'll
get taken for some money by somebody who's trying
to rip us off. But most of us are
not going to be a victim of a grand
scam of the Madoff variety. Um, FORTUNATELY, um, but
I think, I think your first point is exactly
right that, you know, you'd like to think. Oh,
is there a quick, quick fix an easy solution
to not ever being scammed? And that would, that
would be tapping into the hook of potency if
I promised you that if I, if I said
here's all you have to do to avoid ever
being scammed, there is no such thing and we
should know that after reading about the potency that
there's no one quick fix for a really complex
multifaceted problem. Um But I do think there's an
advantage in learning about these hooks. Um It's a
lifelong process to think about when you need to
be skeptical and when you shouldn't. But all of
these hooks and habits are things that underlie almost
all forms of deception so far known and likely
to exist in the future. And as you start
kind of recognizing the patterns, you might start recognizing
when they're at play in times when you're at
risk. So, um one of the strategies that I
think is probably helpful is next time you're listening
to a story about a con or reading an
article about somebody who is taken in, think about
how this con artist applied these hooks and habits.
Um Think about from the victim's perspective, which red
flags did they miss because they were too focused
or because they didn't ask another question when you
start examining the scans and scams in that way,
kind of as we did over the course of
doing our research for the book, you start to
see the patterns and you start to recognizing, start
to recognize when something is maybe a little too
good to be true. Um So I think it's,
I think that's the best approach in general is
to try and understand it from the perspective of
the, of the victim in that moment and how
they were targeted and how they um how the
con artist applied these tricks, um took advantage of
them.
Great. So the book is again, nobody is full.
Why we get taken in and what we can
do about it. I'm leaving a link to it
in the description box down below. And Doctor Simons,
apart from the book, would you like also to
tell people where they can find you and your
work on the internet?
Sure. Yeah, just Dan simons.com. It's the easiest place
to get all the information.
Great. So I'm adding that to the description and
thank you so much again for taking the time
to come on the show. It's been really fun
to talk to you.
My pleasure. Thank you for inviting me.
Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview. Until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by the N Lights
learning and development. Then differently check the website at
N lights.com and also please consider supporting the show
on Patreon or paypal. I would also like to
give a huge thank you to my main patrons
and paypal supporters, Perera Larson, Jerry Muller and Frederick
Suno Bernard Seche O of Alex Adam Castle Matthew
Whitten Bear, no wolf, Tim Ho Erica LJ Connors,
Philip Forrest Connelly. Then the Met Robert Wine in
NAI Z Mark Nevs calling in Holbrook Field, Governor
Mikel Stormer Samuel Andre Francis for Agns Ferus and
H her meal and Lain Jung Y and the
Samuel K Hes Mark Smith J Tom Hummel S
friends, David Sloan Wilson Yaar, Roman Roach Diego, Jan
Punter Romani Charlotte, Bli Nico Barba Adam hunt Pavlo
Stassi Nale medicine, Gary G Alman, Sam of Zed
YPJ Barboza Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Broner. Douglas
Fry Franca, Beto Lati Gilon Cortez Solis Scott Zachary
FTD and W Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgio,
Luke Loki, Georgio Theophano Chris Williams and Peter Wo
David Williams, the Ausa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore Larry Dey junior,
Old Eon Starry Michael Bailey then Spur by Robert
Grassy Zorn, Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radick Mark
Temple, Thomas Dvor Luke Neeson, Chris Tory Kimberley Johnson,
Benjamin Gilbert Jessica. No week in the B brand
Nicholas Carlson Ismael Bensley Man George Katis, Valentine Steinman
Perros, Kate Von Goler, Alexander Albert Liam Dan Biar.
Masoud Ali Mohammadi Perpendicular J Ner Urla. Good enough,
Gregory Hastings David Pins of Sean Nelson, Mike Levin
and Jos Net. A special thanks to my producers
is our web Jim Frank Luca, Toni, Tom Ween,
Bernard N Cortes Dixon, Benedikt Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine
and Patrick Tobin, John Carlman, Negro, Nick Ortiz and
Nick Golden. And to my executive producers, Matthew lavender,
Si Adrian Bogdan Knits and Rosie. Thank you for
all.